[Applaudissements]
je sais je sais je sais je sais bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir kakachi lui il est
cakachi mais lui toi tu es non mais toi
tu es quadra quadra qu très content
d'être là les amis ça fait très très
longtemps que jeis pas venu tu vois
c'est un style à la G mal faudrait exa
non il est stylé quand même ouais mais
il veut toi tu es toi tu es quadrachique
lui il est il est déliciot gr biscuit il
est chocis ch homosexuels g assi le
regret des homosexuels sux pourquoi tu
le dis que maintenant VI par VI par ça
fait des
années
frérot frérot viens on s'assoit de
minutes ici mais non mais attends c'est
parce qu'il me dit un truc important ça
fait 10 ans que je t'ai pas vu de plaire
de plire attends que je pas vu là ça
fait longtemps que je suis pas mais même
on se voit plus j'ai hésité je me dis
j'y vais j'y vais pas euh ouais oua
ouais non pas du tout pas du tout parce
que parfois c'est pas toi qui anime ah
oui un bâtard un bâtard non c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai ok j'ai j'ai un jeu
pour vous j'ai un vrai ou faux vas-y un
jour dans ma vie Béatrice Rosen ah m'a
couru après presque toute une journée
après j'étais habillé en clown
c'est vrai elle m'a assommé avec un vase
pendant mon sommeil elle m'a fait des
trucs chelous non vrai je me suis
réveillé dans une autre dimension dans
une maison lointaine dans une forêt vrai
ou faux vrai vous avez tourné ensem vous
avez tourné
ensemble mais il y a il y a très très
longtemps il y a très longtemps dans une
autre vie vrai ou faux moi aussi je me
suis réveillé avec Matthieu de
lormau
non mais non mais c'est V que tu as
tourné avec j'ai tourné et après on
s'est vu à Los Angeles j'éta ramené oh
et tu m'as forcé parce
que attention demain tu vois lestit
Gad av un BA tu avais un bail avec une
amie comme ba 369 tu avais un bail avec
une amie commune et cette amie commune
habitaé chez moi attends attends mais
qui j'avais un casting le lendemain je
voulais absolument rentrer super tôt et
les relous ils m'ont fait parce qu'ils
avaient pas de voiture ni l'un ni
l'autre à Los Angeles j'ai dû faire tout
et pour trouver son hôtel pour les
ramener et cetera et
voilà j'étais avec toi dans la voiture
oui c'est moi qui conduisais tu étais à
l'arrière tu critiqu ma conduite avec
elle
[Applaudissements]
oui tu étais en Rapp plus du et cétait
qu faut que je rentre bosser mon casting
làou là il est en train de regretter
d'AV tu ve me donner un indice de qui la
person on peut pas dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ici
entendu
ceétais
sûrétais
sû ça me surprendétais Sand elle m'a dit
qui c'était je suis surpris de ne pas
être rentré avec
elle un moment tu étais cela dit tu
aurais pu dire pardon si je peux me
permettre cy tu aurais pu dire le
nom non c'est pas une émission les
choses après buzz ou quoi
c'est c'est une émission
trè c'est une émission intimiste voilà
d'ailleurs les réseaux les réseaux les
réseaux allez-y hein pour qu'on parle de
cette
émission on a besoin de vous on a besoin
de vous c'est toi pourquoi je te vois
plus comme ça mais je sais pas mais je
comprends pas moi je suis là je suis
bien viens on sassoit de second viens
t'assoir avec moi non viens ici à côté
de moi viens à côté de moiiss faire ce
que veux viens sur ma vie viens on prend
un petit ver non viens on prend un petit
verre ici alors on l'amène on l'amène
ici viens on prend un petit ver
amenez-moi une petite table des un
guéridon ils genre ils ont préparé déjà
oh là
là AC nous VI av j'ai envie franchement
parce que non alors tuis ce qu'on va
faire ass-toious ass-toi
assier-i
voir c'est parce que c'est pas parce que
tu ne tu n'es pas connu que tu n'es pas
un acteur
ouais pas entendu tu as dit on est en
tract
acteur il a compris en tracteur je suis
vu dans une improb bidon dans un
tracteur tracteur les mecs vous savez ce
qu'on va faire j'ai envie de faire une
séquence sur ma vie et je vous jure
qu'elle nit pas prévu du tout même lui
n'est pas du tout au cour c'est quoi
séence j'ai envie parce qu'on c'est rare
qu'on est des très grandes stars g pour
moi c'est un ami mais une grande star et
c'est vrai que comme c'est un très très
grand ami j'ai tendance à oublier que
c'est une star et des fois je lu parle
comme une
merde-moi mon
entîn
arrête juste g viens juste de secondes
après juste je te montre juste un truc
et il y a un gars quière quoi il y a
juste un gars frère euh tu sais qu'on
est en plein
hiver frère non mais qu'estce frérot non
mais j'aime bien bien bah tu nous as fa
qui t' fait rêver mais sais elle est où
ta femme la
mais jamais bon ça te voit là elle peut
faire ce qu'elle veut tu veux faire quoi
tu veux faire une entrée tu veux faire
une entrée tu sais quoi tu veux faire
une entrée avec lui non avec moi elle
fait une
entrée
un faites une entrée tous les deux
faites une entrée tous les deux ça te
dérange si je t'appelle
Moussa jeve ça fait star Mouss non mais
c'est vrai franchement j'aime bien ce
soir cy boir là ça va être un truc d'pro
c'est fou l'émission C'est geor c'est
mon manager
ok secondes s'il vous plaît on est en
Italie c'est une émission
italienne
italienêesz ce soir les
amis nous avons la chance d'avoir avec
nous une des plus grandes stars
internationales elle nous amène celui
qui l'a amené jusque là celui qui l'a
pris quand il n'était rien celui qui l'a
amené au fir maman pour la première fois
ce soir vous allez rencontrer c'est son
manager Gadel m et George son
manag
bravo salut
va je su très
content très content de vous
[Applaudissements]
voir il a respecté
famille il est à
fond parce que nous cé je voudrais
remercier parce que voilà c'est rare que
les gens disent un peu voilà parle des
gens qui les ont aidé à les mettre dans
la lumière George c'est quelqu'un qui
m'a jamais lâché dans les tempêtes dans
les tempêtes il a éé non plus tu me
lâches pas pour l'instant non voilà
et non non mais voilà je voulais juste
dire merci en plus il a vécu des choses
terribles et
euh voil surtout avec la
chemise g tu un amour et on t'oubliera
pas bah moi non plus je m'oublierai pas
c'est sympa comme gars ouais tu sais
parce que nous c'était une vanne qu'on
voulait tenir de 3 minutes tu vois là
toi tu es à fond norement il va falloir
retourner à ta tu vois non mais c'est
bon tu vois jeis qu'on applaud
merci bravo beaucoup
ouais je suis pas producteur ouais je
pense qu'on peut avoir une bonne
séquence tu sais ce qu'on fait là g ici
on refait 40 degr à l'ombre de la 3 on a
une minute pour les séduire non alors
c'est pas ça moi c'est pas ça que je
voulais
faire la différence entre les autres
émissions et T PMP c'est que dans les
autres émissions tout ça c'est avant que
l'émission ass-toi 2 minutes je vous le
dis assie-toi 2 minutes c'est le matin
qu'on fait ça les gars moi parce que
c'est je disais c'est une énorme star
moi je vais vous laisser vous vous allez
rencontrer gel Mali voilà c'est une
petite rencontre d'une minute avec G mal
je suis d'accord vous kiffez avec lu
vous avez la chance de lui parler parce
que des stars vous en voyez pas beaucoup
toi qui tu vois parf tout personne
personne toi tu vois que ta mère toi tu
vois des camions toi tu vois des vaccins
et toi tu vois rien voilà et toi tu vois
encore moins al s rigoler moi pardon
j'ai passé des jours avec Elton John et
rou r attention j'adore gade mais j'en
ai vu pour moi pour moi il est auudessus
non pour moi tu es audessus non c'est
différent si diff qu'est tu as envie de
passer un petit moment éal bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
attends poser question tu fais une
interview tu fais une interview tu vois
s'il y a des B interview on dirait un
vieux sketch d'un mec qui va conduire
une
voiture dis
doucement il y a des gens avec qui le
feeling passe ou passe pas mais moi je
pense que ça passe depuis longtemps le
feeling est-ce que c'est parce que j'ai
tout le temps au Maroc que j'ai aussi
cette culture du Maroc ou j'ai envie de
te dire déjà Chakroun d'être là avec moi
ch raelleoi chou
CR est-ce que c'est ça est-ce que c'est
la phrase de Voltaire on est beau que
dans les yeux de l'autre et quand je te
regarde j'ai l'impression
[Musique]
d'exister d'autes chose g un humoriste
c'est pas seulement des textes sinon ça
serait
un humoriste méchant ça non c'est pas
méchant mais un humoriste tu es devenu
méchant méchantaime ça laiss on t'a
demandé
d'intervenirtion c'est vra tu veux boire
un truc ou
pas alors je vais dire la vérité je te
trouve
luisant je te trouve brillant parce
qu'il est ému
hein to tu bois quoi tu bois quoi une
Suse une
suuse ça déjà aès on verra une su de
vieux ça on pe avoir une Suse s'il vous
plaît au-delà des textes tu as un
univers il y a l'univers gade comme et
tu bouges extrêmement bien et moi je
suis très sensible aux gens qui bougent
bien parce que les gens qui bougent bien
et on le sait aussi ce sont les gens qui
on a un univers particul non ce sont des
gens qui bougent bien partout d'accord
euh ce sont des gens qui qui aiment la
vie ce sont des gens qui qui savent qui
connaissent l'amour qui savent faire
l'amour c'est vrai ouais ou c'est vrai
c'est c'est jusque jusque là je tu es
d'accord bah attends laisse-moi ouais
ouais c'est vrai et je sens que tu es tu
es séducteur séduire une une salle comme
ça c'estire des hommes et des femmes moi
tu m'as déjà séduit donc je ne
t'intéresse plus parce que c'est conquis
ouais c'est conquis tu vois mais est-ce
que moi je t'ai un petit peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
séduit moi je suis gêné par cette
scran moi je dis gé pas du tout gêné par
la ouiou on est surtout gêné par cette
personne moi j'ai même oublié les
caméras je suis tellement bien avec toi
avec vous moi je pense qu' tu vas vite
oublier les camér l'amour avec un grand
taas il y a de l'amour il y a du il y a
du désir non moi je suis pas gêné du
tout quoi tu es bien là ouais je suis
bien bah
reviens non mais c'est bon tu l'as parlé
c'est un trucand POS une question non
alors alors si j'ai vraiment un truc à
demander c'est est-ce qu'un jour juste
un jour ser le rêve de ma vie si vous
faites un film ou une scène du théâtre
thre non mais tu peux juste une minute
ouais j'ai j'ai mon rêve çaura ét de
monter sur scène ou de faire un film oh
merde non mais c'est c'est le tien de
parler du covid tu es médecin qu'est-ce
que tu m'emmerdes ah oui bon et c'est
juste un jour et personne personne m'a
jamais donné ma chance personne et donc
la question est-ce que tu lui donnerais
la question c'est est-ce que si par
hasard vous prévoyez un autre film vous
prévoyez du théâtre vous prévoyez un one
man je peux avoir
non
mag frérot mais ça veut pas dire que je
suis passé merci qui veut venir ce soir
Dani tu
veux et vous AZ remarqué la sa plus
belle
tenue c'est vous qui l'avez acheté c'est
moi qui Aché
tu sais c'est pas ce qu'on
trouve au contraire il y a un
look une jovialité mais de l'éducation
nationale il y a un truc c'est quand es
c'est quand tu es convoqué chez le
directeur ou la directrice et en même
temps elle est sympathique pas si grave
quoi tu vois bien votre maesse si vous
[Applaudissements]
assistez soirée qui va terminer je crois
qu'on a un point commun tous les deux on
n pas beaucoup de temps à perdre vous
arrivez à 50
ansb mais qu'estce qui te prends mais
non mais
c'est aller un non mais laisse les gens
s'exprimer non non mais ça va pas ça me
dérange non mais tu peux pas tu peux pas
faire semblant de donner la parole à à
non mais là tuas tuas vu ce qu'elle te
dit ouais mais
ça la cant Paron va commcerission vasy
vasy j'ai une question très très précise
estce que tutais sur dés aveci et
Mathieu qui choisiriez-vous entre les
deux sur une île déserte avec Mathieu et
moi tu sais queass et le temps passe le
temps passe non je réfléchis comme c'est
on est sur tespmp je réfléchis quelles
sont les associations qui
vont quels sont les
hashtag je vous regarde tous les deux je
voisé très puissant ce moment je vois
des hashtags non écoute je je suis
obligé ou sinon tu me il déserte le
temps passe le temps passe sinon tu
meurs même pas il déserte tu es obligé
moi je fais les deux non
arrête-toi j'aime pas les gens qui
choisissent pas un peu de courage ça te
ressemble pas je non je choisis de ne
pas choisir en fait non ça ve dire quoi
mais est-ce qu'on est libre ou pas mais
moi moi je dis la vérité moi je choisis
Daniel ben toi oui alors maintenant la
vérité
moiite et ben prends ton temps mais
répond ben moi j'hésite j'ai pas envie
de mettre au grand jour mon hésite
ça en dit beaucoup bon je repars avec ce
point
d'interrogation je pense
que franchement Daniel Dani tu as dit
quoi Daniel par contre attention je suis
un petit peu dessus là vas-y molo Lao
qui veut qui veut venir qui ve venir
allez viens r viens c'est
le sont heureux ils sont près de toi
salut merci d'être avec nous les Ch si
vous avez des questionsi tu choisira mon
je te jure non non non non Serans moi
pas me choisir juste 30 secondes pour
m'adresser à toi gar tu es celui à qui
on veut ressembler tu es celui à qui on
veut être on veut être marrant comme toi
on veut rentrer dans les soirées être
marrant comme toi alors en 30 secondes
moi je viens ici pour une récrée et je
suis content de rencontrer des gens
comme toi parce que c'était pas prévu
que je rencontre des gens comme toi et
je voulais juste te dire merci parce que
sur un tes sketch où tu dis que tout le
monde laisse des messages au téléphone
et que c'est important de dire papa
viens faire les bisous moi j'ai eu une
histoire avec mon père il y a pas
longtemps j'ai perdu mon papa et grâce à
ton sket je suis parti lui faire des
bisous avant qu'il parte bravo bravo mon
mon ché bravo mon
chéri tu veux te
dis frérot tu veux que te dis la vérité
mais non mais arrête non non je vais te
dire un truc cette séquence est très
forte sur ma vie cette séquence est très
forte et pensees-y pense-y hein qui veut
venir parler je vais t'
embarrasser 2 minutes 2 minutes allez-y
allez-y 2 minutes c'est mon fils je
réponds c'est 19h1 je dois R
oui chéri c'est ton fils oui chéri oui
je sais que tu as l'ENT ah qu'est-ce que
tu veux mon chéri euh euh je te dis un
truc tu as pas de chance d'être à
l'antenne pourquoi bah parce qu'il y a
PS Nasser ah ah ouais ah oui c'est B mat
Amal ouis quel âge il a ton fils 10 ans
j'ai pas de chance bah très bien mon
fils ça va toi
sinon il me connais 10 il conna bien sûr
tu connais Gadel m non mais il sait que
tu es mon ami tu es venu à sa
circoncision ouais c'est vrai d'ailleurs
c'est lui c'est toi c'est toi le bout
encore tu l'aimes bien ouaime bien voil
tu vo'aime bien bon c'est tout tu
voulaisut truc tu
l'adore qui t'embrasse prén tu l'
bienord benam C qui t'embre auss tu
l'aimes bien ça
va guillumeanton salut ma
couille
c'est con ou quoi c'est mon
fils oui chéri bon c'est tout mon chéri
oui c'est tout bon je t'embrasse salut
attends attends je vais faire j'ai un
cadeau pour lui g un cadeau pour toi
comment il s'appelle je sais plus l
ouais tu m'entends ouais ouais tu as
déjà vu les minignons ouais tu connais
le personnage de Grou ouais tu sais que
c'est moi qui fait la voix ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
pas grave je vais rester humble je je je
vais rester humble Nino je voulais te
faire la voix de Grou mais pour toi que
pour toi en live ah vas-y
fais fait professeur nefario
apportez-moi des robots cookies pistogel
nous allons voler la tourfel mais enfin
celle de Las Vegas bonsoir
no il est
fort tu es
[Rires]
contenton bonsoir
Delphine bate je t'aime il a
parl voilà c'est bonors B bonsoir
Delphine comment ça va tu nous
appelles
est-ce que je pourrais avoir un verre
d'eau s'il te plaît aucune émission on
peut demander comme ça à l'emportepièce
à c'est hibiscus obligé de dire je
obligé de dire bien sûr contv bien sûr
tu vas voir c est magnifique tuas trs
bon pour la peiscus regarde-moi
regarde-moi c'est
incroyableiscus alors bonsoir gade je
vous appelle de Boulogne je suis
vraiment ravie de vous
[Rires]
voir
et je voulais vous dire que je voulais
vous dire que je vous admire beaucoup
pourquoi ça me gne ça me gêne que tu me
vous vois mais ça me gêne en même temps
ça me ça m'émous alors je voulais vous
dire que je vous admire beaucoup parce
que vous êtes un artiste complet vous
dansez incroyablement bien vous bougez
votre corps d'une manière incroyable
vous chantez incroyablement bien vous
êtes drôle et en plus de ça vous avez
une curiosité une ouverture au monde et
une spiritu une sagesse incroyable que
j'ai découvert dans votre film qui
s'appelle reste un peu qui est le plus
beau film que j'ai vu de ces dernières
années
[Applaudissements]
braisisis c'est pas beau là tout ce qui
se passez VO cinéma ce film reste il est
incroable elle ai les gens plus âgés je
te le dis ok alors moi je dois juste je
peux passer un coup de
film et gade te
dire plein de surprise c'est plein de
cadeaux en même temps vous ça vous
change parce que c'est toujours la même
chose film carton oui oui ça ouis ouais
on approche les 500000 en incroyable
c'est le film le plus rentable et c'est
un tout petit film enfin dans le budget
la la conception mais je suis très très
très heureux et c'est un film qui
rassemble qui rassemble les communautés
c'est un message de paix important donc
voilà ça c'est mes parents qui jou mes
parents
en France les chéris m'assois ou pas
quelqu'un veut parler encore alors on va
c'est castal tiens viens Benjamin viens
Benjamin ferme
tuas ég
il son
mariage il en a fait il a fait plus de
mariage que
d'mions
euh on se connait depuis très longtemps
depuis très longtemps depuis depuis
Drucker bah depuis Drucker depuis
peut-être 25 ans tout le monde se
connaitt depuis Dr à la télé c'est comme
dans la vie jésuschist c'était avant ou
aprèser voilà tu es venu visiter un
appartement qui m'appartenait à l'époque
oui que je voulais acheter que tu
voulais acheter ça nous a un peu
rapproché ou on s'est croisé beaucoup
sur les et puis est-ce que je
peux je peux dire un truc dont je me
rappelle j'ai dry pe tout dire on on lui
dit tout tu as trouvé des non c'est pas
ça il y avait une batte de BA près de
son lit non c'est vra voilà il m'a
accueilli je le connaissais pas bonjour
il y avait une batte de baseball tu vois
voilà ça c'est ma chambre à coucher avec
une batte de baseball non mais c'est
parce que c à l'époque où il devait déjà
beaucoup d'argent enc on y vient donc on
s'est connu là beaucoup on s'est
beaucoup croiser dans sur les les
compètes de cheval oui je montais à
cheval pas moi pas toi mais une fiancée
et on se croise tout le temps comme quoi
on est vraiment amis dans les dans les
aéroports passe son temps dans le même
lounge complètement et je me disais
puisquon est très amis est vraiment
comme ça est-ce que tu aurais pas 500000
[Applaudissements]
balles écoute pas là pas tout de suite
alors mais non mais arrête là elle était
top la tu es fou toi mais non mais
c'était
génial tu peux pas tu peux pas continuer
après e il a tu as vu il y a il y a ce
qu'on appelle un setup un buildup et une
punchline par c'est le nombre
d'humoriste qui aimerait avoir un rire
comme ça franchement non je do non je
dois ranger je dois ranger
là tu veux vraiment ah non c'est comme
vous voulez vasy si tu veux bien sû ça
être gant j'pè ça ça va être gant g
maisis je su hyper ému gade arrête et je
vais vous expliquer vous êtes un des
regrets de ma vie et là je réalise un
rêve non les regrets c'est il y a
quelques années je vous ai vu marcher
dans les rues de Paris près de la place
de la République je me souviens très
bien je vous ai doublé comme ça vous
n'étiez pas seul c'est le seul mec qui
fait des dépassements sur trottoir et en
fait si vous aviez été seul je Seris
venu vous voir et je vous aurais dit ce
que je vais vous dire là vous êtes pour
moi essentiel dans ma vie je vous ai
toujours admiré adoré juste c'est c'est
pas Fatou non mais je sais mais c'est je
suis vraiment ému je sais c'est un peu
gênant à vous le dire gant parce que
vous êtes un acteur exceptionnel à
l'image de votre dernier spectacle là
parce que vous parlez directement aux
gens et vous m'émouvez chaque fois vous
m'émouvez chaque fois que vous parlez et
quand je vous suis pas venu vous voir
j'ai eu ce regret j'aurais aimé passer
la soirée avec vous comme ça assis sur
une chaise vous dire toute mon
admiration et vous dire que ce que vous
donnez aux gens c'est un bonheur que
vous ne pouvez pas imaginer c'est France
2 là c'est France 2ur c'est le moment
d'arrêter cette section je vous aime
monsieur elmaly voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire
[Applaudissements]
deux choses d'abord merci infiniment et
merci aussi de pas m'avoir arrêé dans la
R